what's up wordsmiths this video is about
the word resistance
it's a noun
it means opposition an effort to stop or
fight something or someone
we could say the developers wanted to
turn the community garden into a parking
lot but they were stopped by stiff
resistance from the neighborhood no
don't yay for gardens right the
community tried hard to stop the
developers they resisted the plan
derivation time this word ultimately
comes from Latin word parts so re
meaning back again or against and
sistere meaning to stand firm to stay
put
so to resist something to express your
resistance is to stand firm against it
consistently again and again
take the next 10 seconds to think of
some English words that contain either
of those elements either re or cyst
ready
let's go
[Music]
here are some that I thought of persist
which means to continue through a
difficult situation per means through
right you you stick with it you stay put
through difficulty
renew which is to start something again
or make something new again like
renewing a checkout from the library or
insist which is to make a forceful
demand to stand firm about something
right I insist on my right to a glazed
donut let's use resistance in a couple
of sentences
Professor Insidious could not poison Ms
excellent because of her legendary
resistance to toxins
that's a uh that's a superhero I just
made up that's her thing she can't be
poisoned she's highly resistant to
poisons ooh that's a good one uh let's
use the adjective form resistant put on
an ant ending there
when they offered to fly me across the
country I was resistant at first that's
our adjective form I was resistant I
didn't want to do it I opposed it
I exhibited resistance I hope that you
do not exhibit resistance to learning
dear wordsmiths because I remain
confident that you can learn anything
David out